mein name ist in bebra ich kandidiere
für die cdu hier bei mir zu hause im
oldenburger münsterland der wahl kreis
cloppenburg vechta die hochburg der cdu
liegt im oldenburger münsterland im
bundestagswahlkreis cloppenburg vechta
hat die partei vor vier jahren 53,1
prozent der zweitstimmen erhalten
bei den erststimmen war es noch
deutlicher 57,7 prozent gingen an silvia
breher was macht ihren wahlkreis aus
also zunächst mal ist es mein zuhause
insofern gehört es ist einfach das
oldenburger münsterland teil von mir
oder ich bin ein glitzer kleines teil
des oldenburger münsterlands ich weiß
nicht ich glaube tatsächlich sind die
menschen die es aus macht die maus ihrer
genese aus der ganzen geschichte heraus
so was entwickelt haben wie etwas machen
wollen etwas zum gelingen bringen wollen
dieses unbedingte durchhalten dieses
irgendeine idee entwickelt damit etwas
gelingt wie ist der zusammenhalt
ob es der unternehmer ist ob es dann im
zweifel der pastor ist oder ob es der
mitarbeiter ist oder der landwirt man
trifft sich zusammen auf dem
schützenfest oder beim kreismusikfest
oder wo auch immer auf dem stoppelmarkt
in vechta hier auf kirmes bei uns in
lindern das ist auch ein sensationelles
ereignis anfang oktober
das macht es aus dass man sich
untereinander kennt das man gesellschaft
übergreifend egal wo du herkommst am
ende sind alle gleich und gehen zusammen
feiern und das macht wirklich diesen
zusammenhalt aus man kennt sich man
verlässt sich auf einander vertrauen
einander und das macht uns stark
warum ist die cdu hier so stark ich
glaube das ist in der geschichte aber
ich kann es auch nicht sagen weil es
auch vor meiner zeit war also da müssen
wir vielleicht mal mit meinem opa oder
mit meinem papa läden aber ich kann es
auch nur von heute erzählen oder von den
letzten 20 jahren in denen ich in dieser
partei bin und es ist eben glaube ich
dieses gefühl gemeinsam kriegen wir das
hin und sich aufeinander verlassen
können und wir haben eben auch beispiele
wo man sich innerhalb der cdu saar ein
wo es stand sich auf splittet davon wird
es nicht besser dann gibt es schwieriger
eine gemeinsame linie zu finden damit
schwieriger auch entscheidungen durch zu
tragen
und insofern ist das glaube ich mit
einem schlüssel das ist schon von jeher
er schwarz ist und man sich dass ich
einfach gute menschen hier gefunden
haben auch gute politikerinnen und
politiker auf allen ebenen also wirklich
kommunal bis am ende zum bundespolitiker
die wirklich gemeinsam an einem strang
gezogen haben für die region
wie nehmen die leute sie war also ich
bin ja schon lange hier also ich komme
hierher ich habe hier immer gearbeitet
ich war ja auch selbstständig als
rechtsanwältin insgesamt im wahlkreis 18
jahre selbständig und sieben jahre auch
schon vorher im job und mir ist es nie
begegnet dass ich nicht ernst genommen
worden wenn auch als junge frau nicht
ich bin mit 27 habe ich mich
selbstständig gemacht als anwältin und
die unternehmer sind zu mir gekommen und
haben gesagt hier sind wir traurig dazu
und ich habe es nie erlebt dass ich als
frau irgendwie nicht ernst genommen
worden bin also das thema war nie eins
ist ihr wahlziel 60 prozent und mehr
darf eigentlich nicht
das werde ich schon ein dass wir nicht
also das wäre schon das wäre schon
erheblich wenn das eine sechs davor wäre
würde ich sagen nur fünf wäre schon top
beziehungsweise mein team sagte auf
jeden fall ist es egal was du was davor
steht aber ist das bundesweit beste
ergebnis ein